now that Trebek was on Good Morning
America this morning talking about his
fight against pancreatic cancer the
Jeopardy host has been blown away by the
support that he's gotten but also isn't
afraid to say that it has been tough but
I've had so many contacts from people
who have survived cancer for ten years
12 years 14 years I am now a 30-day
cancer survivor I'm gonna catch up to
those other people but they have been an
inspiration to me how are you doing my
oncologist tells me I'm doing well even
though I don't always feel it I've had
kidney stones I've had ruptured discs so
I'm used to dealing with pain but what
I'm not used to dealing with is these
surges that come on suddenly of deep
deep sadness and it brings tears to my
eyes I'm I've discovered in this whole
episode ladies and gentlemen that I'm a
bit of a wuss and but I'm fighting
through it my platelets my blood counts
are steady my weight is steady the
numbers that indicate the cancer in the
cancer indicators those are coming down
so I've got another chemo next week and
then we'll do a review to find out where
things stand
bless you for being so honest and
talking about the bat as well as the
good yeah that's so helpful to do yeah
chemo affects people in different ways
and people have to understand that and
there's nothing wrong with saying hey
I'm really depressed today and I have no
idea why why am i crying today been
there done that
yeah mmm it's incredible like I mean
just the share historian yeah that I
mean the fact that he says I read with a
smile on his face he says it's just
thinking about how extra sometimes oh
he's in tears over this but he's still
like he just such a host he's such a
ladies and gentleman yeah he's always
that guy no matter what and so yeah for
the fact that he will confess that you
know he's struggling with this a little
bit it's just incredible and me like
Alex Trebek is in that same sort of Tom
Hanks category of where there's nobody
you'll never find a person who doesn't
like Alex Trebek I mean there's you're
gonna be hard-pressed to find a person
who's indifferent to Alex Trebek
everybody loves Alex Trebek yeah
and but here right he is just always on
like it's the way he speaks and conveys
words in the way he puts them together
that it's almost not real to hear him
talk about this like there's emotion
he's talking about being a person with
emotion but as a person who seems like
they have not like he's talking about
story about someone else that man just
says love Alex hope he beats this
Rebecca says yes he will beat it